this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday
20 is here the joint is brought to you
by cbd lion when it comes to cbd
cbd line is the [__] best out there
in the market how do i know
third party lab results go read them go
to cbd line whether you choose the
capsules
this uh
cbd gummies with melatonin are
tremendous the cream i rub my knees with
them every night my shoulders the
kinesiology tape
i mean listen cbd line
is not short anywhere when it comes to
cbd they even have the dry hump you
could smoke they even have delta nine
delta eight
cbd gummies that'll [__] put you in
another planet so use code joey joint or
church and get 20 off
cbd lion now without further ado
let's get this [__] party
started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what up you bad [__] the day
has come
it's like [__] st joe's day it's four
[__]
20 on the [__] horizon you know
and it's fun to see all the [__] that's
popping up
it's the first 420 in manhattan
so they're basically gonna lose their
[__] minds today i'm doing the
podcast i got to run a couple errands
and then i'm headed over to meet a buddy
of mine for dinner i'm going to eat a
little cabano food
and then i'm going into the city tonight
bump into my girl rachel see what's
going on there
maybe stop by the new york comedy club
see my man over there i got to start
going for it in the city so i like you
know
ever since i've been back i haven't even
[__]
touched my feet over there i've been
over there basically maybe
five [__] times let me see
apple
the audition for apple the premiere
i don't know what else i went in for
it's it's it's sad
it's i even told my wife dear [__] it's
sad that
i've been back here two years
and i could count on my hands
on my one hand how many times i went
into that city the other night we were
watching desperately seeking susan
this is a movie that madonna came out
with and 85. i don't know if nobody even
remembers this [__] movie that's why
when it was on i had like a half hour to
kill
and it was ending so i caught the last
half hour have you never seen
desperately seeking [__] susan
it's uh madonna had baby fat that's how
young she was
she was just a [__] girl you know but
she had blown the [__] up
and she blew up
in the best [__] city in the world to
do
she blew up in new york city so
i mean i still remember being in 85.
i ran in that city from like
that's all i would do i didn't have a
job i was just stealing you know i was
helping a friend of mine
i was stealing things from offices i was
just being a [__] man it was it was
not good
i got a little job before i left and uh
i put the pieces together and then i got
my lawsuit and i got the [__] out of
here but those were like the best
six months of my [__] life i had no
responsibility i lived in fort lee
i would wake up in the morning
like if i would work for like two weeks
put away enough money
maybe bump into a job maybe sell an
ounce of coke and then i would take two
weeks off and then when i would get
broke
i would [__] do the same [__] over
and over again holy i used to put on
like a suit
and go to like fort lee the other side
of fort lee
and they had a bunch of office buildings
and [__] and i would walk through the
office buildings looking for mike is
mike around no there's no mic here i
would just walk in offices looking for
mike when somebody was in the bathroom
or something i rob the [__] office
and take i don't i don't miss that [__]
at all those days i remember still
like my routine was simple i'd wake up
do a little workout on the jersey side
take a shower and uh shoot up walk up to
fort lee
if i had ten dollars i was fine with it
ten dollars is all i needed to get me to
the [__] chinese restaurant and to
get over the city if i had eight dollars
i was fine
because i would eat the chinese lunch i
would go into the name of the restaurant
with these was the enchanted lily
i would go in there
every [__] day guys when i tell you
how we go on the enchanted lily every
[__] day
it was like on main street in fort lee
on the side
i would eat and then i would head to the
[__]
the bridge
and either walk over if i was broke
or if i was living like a doctor like if
i had three bucks forget about it i'm
getting on the [__] bus and i go over
i even had it to the point where i could
front weed
on the streets of new york
i knew the street dealers that i could
front
[__] weed from that is pathetic and
then i asked to join them
and then i sold weed for like an hour
when i robbed
the story of my life i would head over
to 187 write down amsterdam
get two tens
then from there even though i ate
chinese food
i'd go to a park on west side avenue i'd
roll a joint finish it and head into the
[__] 184th and broadway
and i'd [__] get some boliche and
some [__] cuban food and then when i
finished there i'd go back to the park
roll another [__] joint put my
walkman on and just walk
i would start on 184th street and i'd go
let's see how far i could walk down
today and i would go to like 155 see the
a train
walk past it go like the 143rd the a
train walk past it i would get all the
way down to like 125.
i would walk from 184th street to 125th
street with a walkman on listening the
[__] rat
uh the first album i forget the name of
it i had a couple albums in my kit then
i had like rat
i had a couple i had like rat i had
i think i had like one of the black
sabbath times
i had uh what's that [__] youtube
no no yeah i had you two uh
whatever that album is one of the
earlier ones i had a couple things on
[__] and my cd was so good
my cd player i bought an amplifier
you could buy an amplifier for your
walkman in those days so i on 42nd
street i had all those israeli guys
those arabs selling stereos and [__] i
would go in there and [__] get i had
oh my god i had the [__] walkman with
the equalizer
it was louder than [__] people could not
like why do you listen to this i like my
music loud [__]
but back to [__] madonna and
desperately seeking susan
when i saw that movie i used to go to
movies every [__] day every day in 85
i would go to movies maybe three times a
week catch a double feature
on 181st and broadway there there was
like uh
on broadway there was like a black movie
theater i would [__] go in there and
jump up and down with the brothers if i
didn't have enough money to go to movies
with the brothers i would go down two
blocks and there was a movie that like
two bucks
you catch two movies from the 80s like
you know
fistful of dollars and for a few dollars
more like they always had those double
you know they would have like two
clinician movies and that movie did it
was disgusting it doubled as a porno
theater so the floors were sticky and
[__]
if you sat in there in a neutral
position for more than 10 minutes you
better have some nail polish remover for
your [__] sneakers because that [__]
that old sperm is worse than 10 [__]
[__] crazy glue [__] guns
your feet would stick to that
[__] but i didn't give a [__]
i was 21 i was walking around new york
city like i owned the [__] place when
i had dough and when i robbed the gas
station i would shoot into the village
and
[__] buy pills at uh
at washington square park
and go to mcsorley's and have a mug of
[__] beer and oh my god new york city
was such
a [__] playground for a kid
one of the listen one of the biggest
pains i have yes i had like the pain
losing my mother
and the pain of my daughter and another
a ton of pains but i got to be honest
with you the biggest
[__] pain the toughest thing i ever
did in my life
was leave new york city in 85.
because i was on my way i was doing
pretty good when i left and number two
new york city
was on [__] fire you know it's hard i
tell my wife all the time it's tough to
describe new york city to people like i
was telling you guys last week and i
said on stage when new york city catches
a cold
when new york city sneezes
everybody catches a cold and i truly
have always believed that because i saw
the power in new york in 84 if you went
to haiti if you went to new york like i
did and walked around and then you got
on a plane and went to la
two different [__] energies how do i
know cause i did it i was in la for
[__] two weeks in 84
and it sucked compared to new york city
i mean it was a vibrant they had sunset
strip and all that [__]
but new york was new york five [__]
barrows of people getting stabbed you
can't [__] buy that [__] anywhere
else you understand me and when i say
people getting stabbed yeah people
getting stabbed
but you've had a good time in new york
you had a [__] music scene
i gotta be honest that was second to
none
i'm spoiled now like people like jimmy
florentine is always like you want to go
see this show you want to go see that
show not really
not [__] really you know i saw these
bands 30 years ago
in a small place for a third
for a [__] third of what we're paying
now a third
sheila e prince
and nucleus at the [__] ricks or the
roxy you know 15 bucks
15 bucks for prince
nuclear and this is a 1984 album it
don't get no stronger than that but
don't come to me with your [__]
[__] you know i saw all these little
[__] bands all over the place
i went to see chad day at a [__]
restaurant
on the first album in 85 in new york
city who could tell you that [__]
you know i didn't i didn't know where
the [__] i it's not like i was mr
[__] entertainment you know me i'm
not julie mccoy but i had friends that
would go this band is playing here
this guy you know they they were limo
drivers in the city or bartenders in the
city and they had their ear on that [__]
you know they didn't advertise sade
you weren't going to get abattoir you
know i still remember [__] it being
like 80
78 81
like the 81 stones tour
like there were [__] rumors that
they would play niacc
to warm up in the city the stones would
call up a club and say hi the
traveling [__] douche bags
and uh we want to play your club and
they would go okay and often mick jagger
keith richards would walk in and it'd be
[__] ron wood nippy the stones doing
an impromptu set
anywhere in the [__] city that's why
when
when you listen to uh
the rolling stones some girls
you could hear the grittiness of new
york city that's why i'm really proud of
that i was a kid i was a [__] kid and
i watched the stones on saturday live
and all these people going crazy and i'm
like hey that's around the corner from
me
when they were up there [__] doing
shattered and all skinny and [__] on
heroin and jumping up and down they were
doing all that [__] in [__] new york
city
new york city was a [__] metropolis
for a kid it was just a [__] if you
went into the city with 200 bucks
you had the time of your life
pills
cocaine [__] drinking on the street
staying out all [__] afternoon like
all [__] morning how many times i
went into the city at three in the
[__] morning
who goes out at three in the morning
well maybe my buddies will go out like
at 9 30.
sit in a jersey bar until nine about
three and then at three in the morning
go what are we gonna do you gonna go
home
[__] no
we shoot over until we go to this place
ernie's bar on 38th street going from
kelly boulevard down to my old house
after three o'clock ernie would sleep on
this pool table
he would be hammered
and you would bang on the [__] door
ernie open up and he would come out what
the [__] do you want give me two cases
of beer you better have cash and you
better be the full amount
we give them the full amount here the
coldest [__] beer in the world we put
them in spackle buckets
like those buckets of spackle we put ice
on it we get a bag of ice from the beers
were already [__] three-quarters
frozen we shoot into the city we put a
mirror on the hood of the [__] car
we take our beers out and we drink from
3 30 in the morning to possibly 6 6 30
outside
nobody would say a word when you're 18
you know how [__] strong you feel
when you stayed out to say you tell your
friends like what'd you do let's no i
stayed home and watched [__] the
movie with the dog and get the [__] out
of here i went out we went to joe mary's
then at three o'clock we hit the [__]
city we went over there we snorted coke
till seven in the morning we bumped into
some freaks then we came home went to
bed
they'd pick you up at 12 again they
could get a nice little lunch at hash
ways a nice little [__] turkey and
swiss heavy on the salt and pepper
[__] little potato salad a bag of
wise potato chips a can of pepperoncinis
and a 32 ounce [__] coke and then
keep that [__] party alive there
it was just tough to you know
tough to [__] duplicate again and
i'll tell you like i said to you 1985 to
leave new york city
that was a task in itself it broke my
heart i'll never forget that [__]
plane ride going god damn it
i can't believe all these bands are
coming
all these [__] i remember going to
see the last summer i was here
i went to see rod stewart with that
[__] douchebag didn't show up
early in the morning i can't sleep
what's that [__] guy's name uh
the guitar player that's [__] crazy
he [__] canceled i went to see her
lewis in the news
i went to see springsteen i went to see
michael jackson and this [__] six
brothers i went to see prince i saw all
that [__] in 84.
oh my god it was like one after the
other one after the other you figure
[__] had born in the usa
the other [__] michael jackson had
victory tour i mean all this music was
out here look i went to see the
pretenders
dog i'm tanya i went to see the
pretenders at the garden on the [__]
monday night
it was just amazing the concerts that
were coming you'd have all these venues
and [__] the meadowlands in the nassau
coliseum because in the summer all this
[__] would open up the pier and all
those little concert venues on the water
come on now
[__] tremendous like you know it's a
shame like if this was 15 years ago i'd
be in that city four [__] times a
week i'm excited
in a way i'm excited to be going into
the city of duke comedy and i'll tell
you why
i'm a [__] city guy when you look at
me
there is only one place where i'm from
when i open up my mouth
you know i'm from either or but there's
only one place where i remember going
over to [__] harlem when i was a kid
with my friends
and i'd walk out and go get a bag of
weed and go get a [__] bag of potato
chips and a slice of pizza and my
friends were saying to me dog you walk
around that city
like it's second nature
hello
i was [__] raised there you know i
was what do you think i stayed and
played on my [__] computer on tick
tock when i was a [__] eight years
old i was [__] out there dog i did
not you know i look at my daughter this
morning like they don't have no [__]
school
this week so yeah you wake up in the
morning slow let me tell you something
when i was my daughter's age nine if
there was no school
i was out that [__] door at eight a.m
whether it was eight a.m or not cause
i'm one of those [__] that
would move the clock fast on your mother
that [__] was waking up every day to
spring [__] training time you know
when you return the [__] clock i
remember my mother going i don't know
what the [__] happened to me today i got
to work two hours early i wonder what
happens i got to fix my watch i know
exactly what happened i pushed that
watch the [__] out my daughter sits up
there till about 10 30.
then at 10 30 i gotta push her up go
over and call for the [__] pumas and
she'll walk down the corner and she'll
go out you know she's enthusiastic then
another girl came over yesterday and
played here till about two then all the
girls got together and went to the
[__] softball field i mean i'm i'm
honored to go out the dog
you know like i gotta be on her like you
didn't have to tell me one [__] time
like at all like that i had to go out i
was telling [__] uh
my wife the other day of what we did
we used to go to a [__] hardware
store
we would go to chinatown and buy those
[__] kung fu stars and [__] now those
things don't come sharpened i don't know
if you guys know that [__] when you see
them in a magazine and you order them
they come back and you throw them on the
wall and they don't stick you're like
what the [__] i bought a [__]
defective star nah [__]
you got to take him down for the
hardware store and the guy has to put
him in a press
one of those presses
and then with like a rock
and they sharpen and [__] so i remember
we used to go there and
he would go guys i don't really want to
do this
because if you take somebody's eye out
i'm responsible for
dog whose eye are we going to take out
i'll tell you what we're going to do
sharpen the stars and we'll buy [__]
eight chat things
they used to have these check caps right
if you look at your mother's chairs or
any chair at the house
all chairs were not these new [__]
chairs but chairs in the 70s and 80s
and maybe some in the 90s so if you look
at a chair
and you pick it up and you turn it
upside down
it's got those circles on the bottom
that aren't really connected to the
chair it's just a loose piece and it's
got like a screw but if you unloosen
that screw
and take that top off
you'll see that it's like uh
i don't know how to call like a half
moon maybe
where
it's like it's like a cup of soup
but it's metal and you could empty [__]
in there
and when you pull the chair out there's
a black thing in there with a screw that
connects
that's how it connects to that metal
but if you
take the screw out of the [__] chair
you're left with the screw and the
circular piece and then you got to get a
wrench and pull that piece out
and it so now you just have a piece of
metal it's like a bowl it's like an
empty bowl what you do is you get a
crayon whatever color crayon you like
green red pineapple
you take a [__] crayon and you melt
it into those circles
and it gives it weight see they could
play you could play like bottle caps
only with weight like if you take a
bottle cap like on a regular bottle of
pepsi and you fling it that
motherfucker's gonna go 80 miles
because it has nothing to hold it down
but if you put something in there to
kind of hold it down so i don't know who
did it it had to be puerto ricans
because they always play on the street
so puerto ricans [__] melted it and
so all those colors so then you get a
field that says like
one two three four five just like pool
table just like pool it's a box with
numbers and you gotta go from one
to two to three to four to five and if
you get to nine you win the bottle cap
that's the moral of the [__] story so
you basically pay for those [__] caps
and there's big ones there's medium ones
there's little ones
who the [__] knows i i've looked at them
on chairs
so i could show people but they i can't
find them anymore so
who gives a [__] hit him
or something something like not to scuff
the floor who the [__] knows i don't
know i don't give a [__] about the floor
i just try to do the best i can but it's
just so weird that it's the first
[__] 420 in new york they're doing
[__] at webster hall there's got to be
20 concerts tomorrow night have you
noticed that
like i i'm supposed to go i'll find out
everything today
i'll find out anything in about an hour
i'm supposed to go to something this
afternoon
with the dirty jersey boys like a
an affiliate because i do
laughing gas
i do the laughing gas whatever brand
and
one of the rappers on dirty jersey boys
works with the ice cream shop also
but i do laughing gas and he does their
other brand a wii
so what might
what my buddy is trying to do from
laughing gas
is put us together tomorrow this
afternoon i think the party starts at
like five
so i would go to that say hello
shoot up to north bergen meet my buddy
devo
go get a little cuban food we've been
over uh
we're overdue for a little cuban dinner
and then i would shoot over tonight and
see my girl rachel
at [__] the stand i haven't
been to the newsstand at all so i'm
excited about that i'm excited to see my
man brian morton at the new york comedy
club
and uh i think those are the clubs i'll
be working new york comedy club and
the stand because you know
danger feels is done caput
god bless dangerfields
i'm not a comedy seller guy i'm not
gonna sit at a table and
get beat up by other comics i'm not in
the mood for that i'm too [__] old
uh i don't know what happens at
caroline's i don't know what goes on at
the comic strip
you know jimmy farmington told me that
the uh
the one on 74th street's pretty good
i'll call him for spots there
and that's it like i told you
[__] i ain't killing myself
this is nice and easy
i'm just getting back into the habit of
writing every day just sitting down
that's how it all starts you know i had
to rewrite uh
i had to write a read a couple chapters
in the war of art just uh the art of war
the war of art whatever the [__] it is
there's like 18 books on sue johnny
bananas who the [__] knows anymore i
just you know trying to do my best
and uh i'll go over that couple nights a
week i'm looking forward to it man i'm
yeah
i'm ready for the [__] city i've been
hanging out down here in south jersey
[__] three years
i'm ready to go into the city start
cutting this [__] up jack just
twice a week i'm not gonna kill myself
you know come home early i think that
the new york i spoke to
my man the other day the new york comedy
club on 20th street
does show seven nine
and eleven so i always try to catch
the early show [__] uh
i'll try just to [__] close the early
show
try new material listen if i can't come
up with 20 minutes by june
i'm a sack of [__] you know i'm saying
20 minutes i come up with that's why
i decide to do this tour like i said
it's very easy i gotta call bert today
and see what the [__] is going on i
think the tour starts for me
in bristol tennessee which i'm excited
about
i'm a little scared because it's right
outside of
knoxville last time i went to knoxville
the girl sucks my dick and [__] her
boyfriend her husband found out and he
wanted a [__]
he wanted his 40
oh my god
every time i think of that story i i i
think of what i you know going on the
road is great guys you know like i said
i was watching almost famous
the other day and they were talking
about
the amazing [__] people you meet on
the road listen
i gotta be honest with you the road is a
[__] great experience
because you learn
not just your art
but you learn a lot
and michael tell you like when you're in
bands there's always that senior band
member
that he's been in and out of bands for
10 years and you join
[Music]
you look at him like if he like if he's
a god even if he's a [__] bumbling
idiot
because he knows his way through all
these things you sit there like an awe
like just [__] and all like my first
two years on the road dog i was clunky
as [__]
93 94 95 i was [__] clunky the thing
that saved me was i went to seattle
and i had to sit there for a while and
then i started doing you know their
one-nighters and [__] like that and
that's when i started loosening up a
little bit but by the time
by the time i started going on the road
with rogan
i had my [__]
uh
my little schedule on the road you know
because you're starting your own car
first ain't nobody gonna pick you up in
the helicopter bert ain't gonna pick you
up in a private jet that's that's 20
years in
so think of getting beat picked up in
the worst car in the world
think of the book of calling and going
hey i got work for you tonight and you
being a bum like joey going i don't have
a car all right the headliner will pick
you up you just throw them some money
for gas you're like whoo
because i was a [__] loser when i
like i totally remember
nobody shows up to an open mic and a
maserati that's all in the [__]
movies and [__] like that the open mic
is all 300 cars there's one [__]
with a mother lent them a [__] car
and he's got like an audi but besides
that everybody's [__] beat to death
and then you buy a car like when i
started going to the triple runs i was
driving myself and it was great you just
listen i'd rather drive myself
yeah it's better with somebody in the
car they keep you posted but if you
don't like that person that's a long
[__] ride he's talking he's farting
he's burping he's talking about [__] you
don't want to [__] know he probably
wants to listen to lou reed and [__]
crazy music in the [__] car i don't
have time for that [__] and then you
start flying you know when i met joe
luckily you know he would
buy me plane tickets and i would fly
with him and that's a whole complete
different situation you know you got to
get the hotels and
you got to learn how to [__] land at
the airport and where your luggage and
who picks you up and every club is
different they don't pick you up they
pick you up you know you have to
sometimes you got to pay 90 you're
getting 500 for the week
500 from wednesday to sunday and you
gotta pay 90 dollars for a cab ride
from the [__]
assumed and listen guys
assume that no hotel
is gonna be five minutes from the ho
from the [__] airport that's never
gonna [__] happen
you just and now at least you could like
go on your [__]
maps what's it called waves you go on
your waves to see what it's gonna cost
you how far it is you know you go on
your uber and go oh [__] it's going to
cost me 80 bucks
i'm [__] dead but think about that
you just so you have to learn bus
systems
you know it's either this 90
or i eat subway sandwiches all week
[__] veggie and cheese
you know i got to figure out how to turn
that 90
into five hours
and then i could eat a good dinner two
nights and maybe pick up a half a gram
of coke one night you know what i'm
saying but why are you gonna throw 50 90
on a [__] ride
some guy the other day
a nice kid on patreon was telling me
like you know trying to cut me down like
yo
so you understand you're gonna go on the
road and [__] there's gonna be
drinking and a lot of booze and you're
not gonna be able to drink because
you're a dad and all this [__] i think
it's gonna be very rough on you and i'm
like
first off you're starting to sound like
a [__] hater
you this is what you do to yourself this
is what peop when you look at those type
of emails you have to assume that this
is what people do themselves
when they think of seeing something new
like when they present an opportunity to
their own brain this is what their brain
does to them
you see what i'm saying so i'll say all
those things you're going to do this
you're going to be around alcohol and i
was like
what the [__] do you think what the [__]
do you think you're talking to
i've been around alcohol for 50 [__]
years i'm 59 years old i've been around
alcohol for 58 [__] years what are
you talking about i don't drink
not because i'm a friend of john's or
because i might get a dui i don't drink
because i don't like the [__] taste
of vodka i don't drink because i don't
like the [__] taste of wine i don't
drink because i like the taste of
[__] scotch i just don't like it
so bert and that whole crew they could
light themselves on fire for all i give
a [__] obviously you don't know me too
well
you don't know that pressure don't do
victory i don't give a [__] how much it
listen
as long as i got my reefer you go [__]
yourself and if the bus gets a little
crazy either two things are gonna happen
he that put a gun to the [__] drive
his head and i [__] take over the bus
christopher columbus [__] style like
speed two nobody does [__] on this
[__] or
i tell the bus driver to pull over at
the next hotel and i abandon ship and go
to the hotel on my own obviously you
guys don't have a [__] clue how i do
things if something ain't going my way
i pack my bags and go home
i'm not gonna argue
i'm not gonna do hand to hand combat i
don't give a [__]
it's four [__] shows i don't give a
[__] if bert's in a bubble bath with
[__] tito's the whole [__] four
shows it doesn't do you understand me
guys this [__] doesn't do anything to me
they have you should be worrying about
those [__]
because you got to make sure i don't
come on with a bag of [__] abx
edibles and you [__] got to
make sure you said i'm saying don't
worry about me
worry about them
i've been doing this [__] for a long
[__] time you're not going to derail
me nothing you could do could [__]
derail me i've heard all the stories
already mike over here is trying to talk
to me before about uh
[__] breaking back go [__] yourself i
don't like breaking bad nothing you tell
me is going to change my mind
like when people come up to me like you
got to do that i don't have to do
dick i've had so many people
tell me right out that i'm a hard nut to
crack there was this dude on facebook
joe warner that for years this
[__] would reach out to me every
day
with some story or whatever he doesn't
see he doesn't know that i would see the
story coming a mile away there was this
girl that used to [__] i met her in
vegas hello goodbye
very nice dirty chick you know i liked
her
but every week it was a different my
[__]
like you and joe rogan should come to
utah for what
for what to hang out with mormons what
am i doing [__] you thought
every week she had a different mind [__]
you and ari and everybody should rent
doing buggies and do that when do you
want me to find time
to rent dune buggies
in between the podcast and [__] going
to the what what the [__] are you
talking about
so finally i had to tell like what are
you talking about she's like you and
you're the hardest nut i've ever had
don't worry about cracking me
just live your [__] life
don't worry about cracking me or trying
to figure me out you're in no [__]
danger figuring me the [__] out i can't
figure myself out when i talk to my
therapist over at betterhelp she [__]
shakes her [__] head so what are you
gonna do
what do you want to [__] do
that's what people don't understand
about me if i don't want to [__] do
something
i won't do it
did you just see what happened the last
two years
they were calling me every day i had to
tell the agent go away don't call this
number no more and he finally went away
you could call me every day you could
borrow me every day
if i'm not going to do something
if i don't want to do it
i'm not going to [__] do it i lost
friends over it i have a friend right
now that once told me
man when you don't want to do something
you refuse to do it i i don't want to do
dick
and people can't figure it out they get
mad at me don't i had a party you didn't
come
i'm not going to tell you why i didn't
come to your party
i'm going to tell you they have a cousin
that drives me [__] crazy
you know i have these friends now that
always invite me to this [__]
i love them to death but they got a he's
got like a friend that drives me [__]
crazy and he comes to everything he
always wants to talk to me about stupid
[__] you know those people like when
you're watching a game and they want to
come over and ask you like stupid
questions i can't deal with that [__]
but he's so tight with him i can't
insult him either so i just bow out i
just don't do anything with them because
i know
that if i get three [__] bong hits on
me or something this guy starts getting
me an ear beating i'm gonna go off and i
don't want to go off so that's a lot of
people understand ah
guys i didn't give a [__] when i was 25.
what makes you think
i give a [__] now did you ever think
about that [__]
like what makes you think
when i was 25 i put a gun to a
motherfucker's head
and put him in the trunk of a car and
that was one of many guys that was the
ones that you heard of i'm still sitting
here every [__] day going one of
these guys gonna pop up back in my life
hey 30 years ago joey diaz put a gun to
my head and harlem these guys don't
[__] they don't they're not part of
the world culture i guess they don't
want to see me
i'm dying for one of these idiots to pop
up and say hey man 31 years ago i i
looked at the pictures and i remembered
it was joey who tied me up in an
apartment in harlem nobody's [__]
said nothing that was me that was
[__] who i was i'm not proud of that
i'm not proud of that [__] animal
anyway you know i looked at the picture
of me there there
we were watching molly's game and we're
talking about snow or something like
that and i was trying to show mercy like
the colorado caps you know like the snow
and she's like daddy that was you and i
go
i guess
she's like what do you mean you guess i
go i guess that was me everybody tells
me it's me i don't know who that [__]
guy is
i don't remember that guy that guy
whatever the [__] he was thinking about
right there that picture of me standing
there with the white t-shirt god knows
what i was thinking about mugging
robin snorting jumping out of a plane
who the [__] knows at that age i don't
know who that [__] guy is i feel bad
for that guy not really
i mean but i when i think of my life at
that time
i feel kind of bad for me how lost and
confused and [__] uh
stupid i [__] was but
we live we learn and i'm not that person
no more but
i still got that picture
and it's me nothing you could [__] do
i got to get all those pictures and send
them to the book people anyway
they want to see a bunch of they're like
oh just send us the pictures i go dog
this picture
like maybe eight of them that you could
[__] use i've been going through
those pictures lately
i got those two pictures of my mom that
that kind of foggy i got this one
that you see every [__] day you're
not gonna want to see the book
so i don't know what we're going to do
with the book but the book has an
official
[__] release date
of may 23rd 2023
i know
that's a long [__] time away but
i'm not the company i didn't pay me so
they could do whatever the [__] they
want now back to [__] 420.
i was thinking about 4 20 last night and
i got to tell you who i missed the most
i'm 420
and that's ralphie may me ralphie
felipe sparser i gotta call him today
uh rodrigo torres
there was a year we did like a run
of like eight shows in weed stores
all over la we were so [__] broke
we had no money for weed we basically
had money for like lunch or something
that day i'm never i don't even know
what year this was
if i have to guess
they started doing
all the 420 all the weed stores started
doing comedy shows like
2001 2002
and you know i mean [__] guys they paid
50 bucks
and an eighth of weed and you could
smoke as much weed as you could
while you were there are you [__]
kidding me
and they give you a deal on the weed so
basically
you bought weed a deal you know
but we would do
the [__] kushmart
cushmart pay this the best so we would
do them first
i remember they had a back room me
felipe
i i can't even tell you how many edwin
san juan
we traveled in a group those years
on those 420s it had to be
three cars
five of us in each [__] car we were
just parking unloading these weed stores
there was even that doctor
when i first got my first license it was
three
hundred dollars
no for the license
like in 99 2000
it's 250 now i hear i think in jersey i
think it could be a little cheaper in
jersey but when the licenses first came
out and like they were 200 i'm like i
can't afford 200 bucks
it was rogan who took me and brian
to a doctor
i forget the [__] street this guy was
a wackadoo he had gone to jail for doing
something and rogan took us up there
the guy knew rogan from somewhere and
[__]
and rogan was like
yeah give him all licenses i'm like
i got 30 dollars in my pocket i hope
rogan doesn't think i'm paying for this
[__] license
and when the bill came he paid for it
and goes you guys got a license now like
what the [__]
and i'll never forget we used to go to
cushmart
we used to go to that weed store on
beverly that had a there was a weed
storm mic that had a backyard
and these [__] built a stand
like uh not a stand what the [__] am i
saying they built the stage they built
the sides
they would have [__] comedy shows
they started on 4 20 and then after that
the owner called us
he's like what do you guys think can we
do this all the time
we were doing happy hour comedy shows
we were doing a happy hour comedy shows
at weed stores
so we would do like there would be 30
people in a room
30 40 people but
we would do the happy hour from like
five to seven
the
owner of the wheat store would say just
bring as many guys as you can just book
to show yourselves
i'll give you 300 bucks and a half ounce
of weed we'll be there at five o'clock
[__]
and we [__] go there he'd give us an
ounce
ralphie edward san juan george perez
they would be rolling joints we'd be on
stage bombing
because it's tough to make those
potheads [__] laugh you know that
can't make those [__] laugh
we'd be up there [__] bomb and that
was such a long time ago
but it was such i mean
when i think of those times in comedy
man
at the time you don't think you're
having a good time you're broke you
really want money you really want to hit
it
you don't have the things you want but
i'll tell you what man as far as
laughter
we were so rich and laughter back then
we really [__] were man
josh wolfe
and everybody had a different spot like
everybody would say well i talked to
this guy up on ventura and he told us to
go by at eight o'clock we would just get
together and go what places are we going
to and how much are we going to mug them
for
you know how much weed are we getting
and we would just [__] hit like four
or five spots we would start at like 3
30.
ari
i remember one year with ari when we got
that [__] third eye weed and it was
[__] dangerous and [__] and we told
everybody about it and then we went back
and they didn't have any more of that
weed this is so i mean guys
the times we had in those [__] 420s
and those weed stores
i can't even [__] start to tell you
now
yeah they were doing a comedy story they
were doing a comedy uh
they were doing a comedy show at this
one weed store up in the valley i never
went to it we were over it by that but
jesus christ dog they had a wheat store
we used to go to
i can't remember where the [__] it is
now
these guys were 20 years ahead of that
time
all right because most weed stores when
you go there
in reality you can't smoke there
they sell you on it they'll say you know
we need to get high
but they don't you can't spark that they
have a security guard
but this one place they were breaking
all the [__] rules
and it was a weed bar
that's what they called it a weed bar so
it was a weed store
you went to the store you bought weed
and once you bought weed
if you knew the cold like you know
stinky [__] or whatever the [__] it was
every day
they blink and the guy would open the
back door and you go back then it was he
built the [__] great bar i forget
where this [__] weed store was he
built a great little bar
and each station
each chair had like a bong
and like three four two feet around you
and they had like little things to grind
your weed it was the guy really [__]
hit a home run with it
he built a little stage
straight ahead so there was a bar when
you walked in you walked in
and there was maybe a bar on this side
with 15 seats and maybe a bar that way
with 15 [__] feet
you could buy weed right there like when
you walked in she would buy you either
sell you joints or grams
ash
and they even had something for the like
the bong they would come over first and
you'd rinse the bond
i'm telling you this was
state-of-the-art [__] weed store i
don't know what happened to it you know
when people put that much of investment
you know we you know like
just before i left l.a before the
pandemic
some nights i would go down to meet my
agents at dantanas or one of the
restaurants
and i would see [__] you know and i'm in
one night i was at a light
and just you know there's a light in you
it's dark out but obviously there's a
reflection on your face and you're like
what the [__] is this
i'll never forget i looked over to the
left
guys there was a weed store
the size of a [__]
of el nido
you know
just this [__] wheat store with
beautiful [__] lights
and everybody had like a
an ipad and they come up to you and you
had to go to the back and get it was too
much
and i remember sitting there going it's
a beautiful [__] store
but how many grams do you have to sell
to keep the [__] lights on
it's a lot of grams of 20 a piece g it's
a lot of [__] weed at 20 a piece say
you make eight bucks a gram that's a lot
of [__] grams that ain't gonna last
doesn't take a genius to tell you the
overhead's gonna kill you between the
overhead the nice white college educated
kids and that ipad bill it's gonna
[__] kill you
it's gonna kill you you know people want
people uh
on 420 with weed you want to be a little
bit more personal with people
the stores i always look i like the ice
cream shop and i'll tell you why
because
when you went in there
first off they had everything
i never wanted for anything in there
if i wanted [__] thc bubble gum they
had it might not be any good
but they gave me the option i remember
when we were hooked on the
cbd water with the oxygen [__] great
nine dollars a bottle
nine dollars a [__] bottle
and people were going up to every day
for a [__] bottle of
16 ounce cbd water you know they just
got everything but those places you know
you got a lot they're small
like ice cream shop used to be way
[__] bigger and they got a dose of
[__] reality this that and then they
shrunk it down the ski shop
but you know you got to get to keep your
[__] place
small and [__] how you gonna
and that's what happened with that dude
my point is that's what happened
he spent i mean there were 40 [__]
bongs alone
see what the the ice cream see what the
freeze pipe cost you for the bonk think
of getting 40 of those even if you knock
off 20 bucks for wholesale
and and then he had like 10 of those
ones that with the with the fish
uh
with the [__] fish thing you know the
fish you ever get a fish tank and it
comes with the little engine
no in this
sorry about that i'm too old for these
these new wave kids in the old days you
got a fish tank right and the filter was
like this white thing you got to put
rocks in there but like a cotton ball
and something else and then seal it and
the water ran through that filter that's
how you kept it clean now it's done
whatever but to keep to keep that water
pumping you had a little white engine
that had like a cord and it just went
down all day i don't know what it was 10
ball battery you [__] electricians at
home can tell me what the [__] it is i'm
not good with this [__]
so what you do is you disconnect that a
lot of people are doing the puerto rican
way we're building an engine and that
little engine from the fish tank they
were surplus they were going on ebay and
getting them
and they work as those things that push
the smoke into you
so he was getting those things built
like i'm telling you guys he had the
dabs way before dabs with dabs
i can't remember where this [__]
store was and i think thursday nights
they did comedy they gave you 50 cash
and an eighth you know i leave with like
120 and a pound
because everybody gave you something you
know
bad hash but man that that's the way i
would do it
but that was the only place that you
could sit there
watch comedy smoke dope you know for as
long as you could before somebody hits
you with a [__] weed breath and you
gotta get the [__] out of there but
yeah i had some good 420s in l.a so i'm
excited to see what 420 in new york is
going to be like
i'm showing up over there with a couple
[__] ounces of weed
you know uncle joey we're going in
[__] deep we're not [__] around
here
and that's it you bad [__]
it's the wednesday 4 20 edition
of the [__] joint that's why we call
it the joint when mike got here we
smoked the [__] joint he got a lot
higher than i did
i i don't know what the [__] going on
with me i gotta [__] uh spin it
around i think i smoked the joint right
we smoked uh
oh no yours was a lot bigger than mine i
had i had the little [__] [__]
joint the little hammerhead does the
trick you know gets you where you need
to [__] be
but that's it you bad [__] uh
i love you guys with all my heart
we have a guest lined up for next week
couple guessed the next one we had one
today
but he got all 420 out last night and he
couldn't [__] uh he took an edible or
some [__] he couldn't do 11 o'clock in
l.a but we'll be back next week ready to
[__] go i don't know if you guys
are watching the [__] nba playoffs
[__] tremendous
i've been making some money go by
draftking say hello
don't treat him like a [__]
redheaded stepchild there's money there
there's some great games you got [__]
phoenix new orleans
you got philadelphia toronto they're
taking it back to toronto you got some
great games i'm happy that i'm watching
[__] sports again i'm getting into it
a little bit plus now with the stand up
it's going to be [__] better i'm not
as bored as i was just knowing that i
have that option i feel a lot [__]
better but i gotta thank you guys for
all your support
and uh i'll keep you posted
when i know more about the tour dates
and where the [__] we're going i haven't
spoken to bert god knows where that
[__] is i think he's going to
the moon with elon musk or whatever the
[__] he's doing they're going to take
over twitter together i don't know what
the [__] they're doing i love you
[__] stay black
thank you for the support have a happy
and safe
420 don't smoke no fentanyl balls
and [__] i'll see you [__]
next monday morning tip top magoo ready
to go stay black [__]
all right you bad [__] it's 4
20.
thank you for listening to the joint
thank you
for watching the joint
it's 4 20 and i'm ready to go the joint
is brought to you by
cbd lion when it comes to cbd
cbd lion is the best how do i know read
the third party lab results do you know
what cbd is do you know what cbo is no
so get to it [__] go to cbd lion
read the third party lab results whether
you need the kinesiology tape the
chocolate the dark chocolate and milk
chocolate they have delta nine gummies
with cbd they got cbd gummies with
melatonin to help you sleep cbd lion has
it all go to
cbdlion.com and look at what they have
to offer press code joey i love you
[__] with all my heart i want
to thank
cbd lucy.com
zip recruiter on it i mean
you know better help is tremendous
and i also want to thank
freeze pipe the freeze pipe
for their support
the best pipe to use on 420 [__]
have a great week have a great weekend
and i'll see you [__] tip
top magoo monday morning ready to rock
stay black
[Music]
you